[Music]
well congratulations thank you so much
for being here
you're obviously a brilliant you're very
beautiful very cool to have you on the
program you just want to get it clearly
hasn't gone to your head
only I can flip my hair here tell us
about yourself you're 18 and you're
crazy or you're graduating I'm 18 I just
graduated last week from high school I
live in Saratoga California
congratulations and you're off to
college
heading to Harvard this fall oh very
good good luck with that place that's
really exciting so you're headed off to
Harvard and and and all of this began
because you were frustrated with your
cellphone dying a lot of us feel that
frustration have felt that frustration
but we don't go out and invent a way to
fix it I just throw my cell phone and
then yell at my assistant and then she
says you're a monster
I say quiet way too much about me but no
you um your cell phone was dying and you
wanted to fix this problem yes so I
actually had a stone-age phone like a
brick of a phone all I could do was call
I didn't act I still don't know how to
text a text like this what kind of phone
is this you're using it like literally a
brick okay a brick okay so you had the
very clunky phone and it was dying on
you yes and what was the problem what is
the problem that happens just not enough
battery life battery you would die and I
get frustrated and unlike you I couldn't
throw my phone so I really they don't
let me do that but I'd like to oh I'd
like to go ahead yes I wanted to figure
out a way to basically increase the
amount of energy construing with my new
project okay now in this in this contest
they were in you're up against 1600
people is that right were you
intimidated I mean these are some and
probably very intimidating competition
and I've been to that Intel competition
and it's amazing what these young people
are coming up with yes and as people
from all over on the world but the
scariest thing is their titles so as a
science fair kid you are not to look at
people's titles because there
unbelievably scary people are curing
cancer like making robotic arms doing
all sorts of crazy things so do not look
at titles right because the titles just
promise a lot does anyone try and psych
you out did any other kids come by your
thing and go mmm cell phone storage all
right flip your hair and say talk to the
hand no one does that anymore what was
the title of the project that you won
for I worked on the design and synthesis
of hydrogen via titanium dioxide
polyaniline core-shell nanorods
for flexible high-performance super
capacitors okay
[Music]
I've done a lot of work in that field
curious how you're coming along with it
I've made great strides myself okay what
is that okay give it in layman's terms
what is it you were doing there I mean I
don't understand any of that well yeah
so what I did was make a new type of
energy storage device which can store a
lot more energy and it can charge very
quickly they actually have it here to
show okay looks like this that's it
look at that it's like a I'm sorry I
don't want to damage it at all what is
this made of tell us how you invented
this or how you made this development
and basically it's a carbon fiber with
different metal oxides and all these
complicated materials on it that are
very smaller than in now you're
condescending to me you're like it's
made of some complicated materials Conan
it's made of some magical beans I can
handle it tell me what's in there what
materials we talking about titanium
dioxide and polyaniline okay got it
maybe I'll go make one it shows you
where I'm at I'm just like I just like
the box it comes in like it's pretty
it's like a peace sign okay can we take
this out of the box or does it stay in
the box at all times you can't touch it
but I can okay I think I literally can't
touch it cuz what would happen if I
touch that well you would probably break
it
Wow that's so and so that strip now it's
what's what's happening there what is
this going to what can it do it can
absorb where does it get the energy from
so you have to charge it with like how
you charge the cell phone battery charge
and you put charge in it and it stores
it and you just connect to something and
it discharges